indica en la frontera entre polonia y
ucrania cada día miles de personas
llegan huyendo de la guerra mujeres
niños y ancianos son la gran mayoría de
escenas de voluntarios de todo el mundo
y llegan para apoyar y a veces
transportar refugiados a otros países de
la unión europea como alexandre que
recorrió cientos de kilómetros para
prestar ayuda
somos un grupo de gente de españa de
alicante de elche que hemos decidido
al reunirnos hemos acumulado algo de
dinero hemos traído siete furgones de
ayuda humanitaria y ahora podemos
recoger un treinta y dos personas las
más necesitadas tenemos donde ubicarlas
tenemos casas alojamiento todo escuela y
naciones de luján que acaba de cruzar la
frontera ella y su familia abandonaron
su hogar durante el conflicto de 2014 y
de nuevo debe dejar su vida atrás esta
vez acepta la oferta de alexander y
me proponen ir a españa quiero ir allí
como no hay nada que me impida ir
en luján lo perdimos todo tenía una
tienda teníamos una casa grande era
empresaria ahora no me queda nada
los esfuerzos de álex tanto como los de
tantos otros le permitirán a ina ya los
suyos empezar una nueva vida lejos de la
guerra mientras que uno de cada cuatro
ucranianos son desplazados internos y
refugiados en otros países